Every day I wake up knowing that the more people I try to save, the more enemies I will make.
And it's just a matter of time before I face those with more power than I can overcome.
I'm so sorry, I'm late.
I had a traffic thing.
Did your traffic jam have anything to do with being, I don't know, shot at by machine guns.
Yeah, yeah that was implied, I was implying that.
Peter Parker.
Harry Osborn.
You're gonna want to see this.
Oscorp had you under surveillance.
Why?
Isn't that the question of the day.
There's something you're not telling me, Aunt May.
I once told you secrets have a cost.
The truth does too.
My name is Richard Parker, I have discovered what Oscorp was going to use my research for.
I have a responsibility to protect the world from what I know they're capable of.
What is all this?
The future.
We literally can change the world.
What about Peter?
Not everyone has a happy ending.
This is bigger than you, Peter.
I made a choice.
This is my path.
Soon, everyone in this city will know how it feels to live in a world...
...without power, without mercy, without Spider-Man.